même à l'écart des grandes villes on n'y
échappe pas depuis ce matin dans ce
restaurant ces lavages de mains
obligatoire à l'extérieur et contrôles
d'identité à l'intérieur
je vais prendre moi quoi j'ai eu des
lots t jet prendre également numéro de
téléphone 72 donc voilà aujourd'hui on
prend vos coordonnées puisque maintenant
avec le nouveau protocole sanitaire on
obligé de tenir un cahier de rappel et
donc on à vos coordonnées pendant 14
jours bout de 14 jours ils sont détruits
récolter les données personnelles
une mesure désormais nationale
permettant de repérer les 4 go vides la
plupart des clients s'y plient
volontiers 60 n'ont pas le choix donc
c'est la meilleure façon de combattre et
un peu ce virus là de par la prévention
donc moi je suis pour parmi les autres
mesures du nouveau protocole pas plus de
six clients par table ou encore port du
masque obligatoire tant que l'assiette
n'est pas servi moi je pense que tant
qu'on peut enlever le masque pour manger
c'est pas mal vous allez continuer aller
au restaurant oui oui oui j'aimerai
toujours faim donc
on a tendance des fois faire la police
avec certains clients pas tout le monde
heureusement
heureusement la majorité sont
compréhensibles mais à un moment donné
il faut que tout le monde y met du sien
parce que sinon on ira on n'y arrivera
pas car à vesoul comme dans plusieurs
grandes villes beaucoup voient d'un
mauvais oeil ces nouvelles mesures
dix restaurateurs de la capitale haut
saônoise ont déjà mis la clé sous la
porte à cause du confinement
on a le protocole de plus draconiens
parce qu'on parle pas des autres métiers
il ya d autres métiers où il ya des
commerces
il ya d autres métiers où on rentre dans
les établissements où nous demande pas
notre nom n'ont pas pourquoi la
restauration en est stigmatisée par
cette maladie en haute saône
la situation sanitaire se dégrade la
plus grande crainte des restaurateurs
désormais et que l'on m'annonce un
couvre-feu général au cours des
prochaines semaines
[Musique]